bonjour comment vous allez moi ça va
extrêmement bien clément sahara on s'en
fout aujourd'hui on va jouer à quoi a
débuté les câbles c'est faux je devrais
bloody mary ce lundi dans lequel nous
incarnons un enfant de 11 ans en pyjama
rayé très très beau le même que tu avais
mis hier soir pour dormir fait pas genre
on va se poser devant le miroir de salle
de bain comme ça et on va faire ce qu'on
a tous souffert qu'on avait 11 ans dames
blanches dame blanche dame blanche
devant un miroir à minuit en espérant
qu'elle vienne mais pas trop ces partis
invoquons bloody mary
[Musique]
alors on a donc un bonjour anne déjà pas
pourquoi ça rame voilà on a donc un
téléphone et des bougies suppose qu'il
faut éteindre la lumière adorateurs
macgé crise a atteint une tâche et 15
ont mis les doigts dans la prise
j'aime dessus oui l'interrupteur de
cette salle de bruxelles portent fait
huit mètres 20 où l interrupteur
il ya bien un bon résister quoi on va
lui mais en même temps il faut allumer
les bougies avant je pense à lacaune
ical il perd pas de temps c'est parfait
on y va ok ça s'est éteint tout seul
et du coup ça va et plus tu me crois en
fait quand tu lac sur un jeu vous
éteindre la lumière voilà c'était c'est
le bilan de cette vidéo kg allumer les
bougies
ok qu'est ce qui se passe oh ça c'est un
savagnin ma fenêtre c'est sûr tu parais
combien je peux pas allumé la radio pour
me rassurer
c'est matt énergie tombé sur le la
nouvelle chanson de jules oh ça a bougé
derrière c'est à bouger derrière le
rideau
c'est bon il ya un travers j'ai regardé
ya rien je préfère pas l'ouvrir c'est
quoi ça oh là là on dirait une autre
dimension avec faudra le projet un
projet en même temps je rallume c'est
bon c'est bon élément je suis protégé à
7 m/s elle a fait dégager a eu le bon
réflexe favorite
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle revient à
l'écran n'est qu'il faut faire allumer
les bougies
j'arrête pas de rallumer les bougies ça
fait briller le jeu alors à tenter dans
les tiroirs il ya des choses mais kayhan
lampe torche dans un tiroir dans le
tiroir il ya un bouquin il ya un beau
quinté plus a récité un truc genre
satanas tripoli cathy c'est du latin bon
mec j'ai lu le livre et ils disent rien
le fou dedans donc après ce que j'ai
d'autres séailles incana là dessus je
pense qu'il faut réussir à ouvrir le
cadenas et là dedans on va avoir quelque
chose d'utile
mais du coup et la clé c'est ça la
question bon dieu ce qu'on va faire mais
que je pense qu'on va prendre la lite là
y'a rien là y'a rien et si j'ai apte et
dans la poubelle la clé c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne cachette ses idées de
merde mais bon c'est moi qui milite dans
la poubelle dans sa deuxième livre ça
c'est un deuxième livre c'est un
deuxième livre à temps il faut juste de
seconde que je fasse
hop hop alors que ribéry avait gardé son
single qui en fait c'est les paroles
d'une chanson juste c'est juste les
paroles d'une chanson c'est nul à chier
ça m'aide pas du tout
[Musique]
ok on voit cette fois on va réussir en
gros le but je n'avais pas compris mais
ces deux là buté postulat vote pour
faire un petit goût dans le cas selon
lui vraiment il est à la steppe du
dessus on l aime toutes les bougies
ok madame est une maligne elle à vouloir
arriver par la fenêtre kellar clément
panique pas si tu paniques j'ai paniqué
tu paniques pas voilà le rideau qui
bouge on brûle le rideau maman appelle
les pompiers fin du jeu le téléphone
sonne je réponds avec l'allumette tuque
après est résistant à l'eau les
téléphones sur les hauteurs à quoi aux
flammes
ça marche pas la fenêtre s'ouvre bloody
mary rente et allaitant les bougies et
pour ne pas mourir ce qu'il faut faire
c'est rallumer les bougies là on attend
qu'elle rende va se dire en mai toi bien
mais ses cousines met toi bien mais tout
va bien on ferme la fenêtre up et on
allume les quatre bougies et là qu'est
ce qu'elle fait masser faisait dans le
miroir normalement la les aubes là les
hommes le miroir se baisse et sur les
chiottes merde c'est pas prévu ça ferais
tu met les boules et mes bougies on
rallume les bougies oui ah je sais tirer
la chasse tiré la chasse
ça a marché une fois je crois pas donc
là elle vient hop ça dégage
oh c'est bon ça a marché mais qui peut
aller attendre un petit peu tirer la
chasse et elle m'a la chine clé nikkei
qui va servir à quoi à ouvrir le kanak
alors annoncé qu'une moitié de clessé ça
j'ai qu'une moitié est là elle et elle
n'est pas là dedans match clé wahou
onex avenir dans la baignoire à ce
seront plus de sa tête le pq en voix et
le pq t elle
il ya du sang de ouf fait faux bon je
sais pas je suis dans la peau pâle à la
porte est ouverte
non non non c'est pas ça c'est s'ouvrir
c'est pas censé sourire merde merde
merde voilà c'est bon c'est bloqué elle
est où oui c'est bon j'ai la deuxième
clé fallait juste bloquer la porte
[ __ ] je le savais clément ok le cas
demain à dégager et habib ben oui on
perd pas de temps aux aléas les dég la
paix à la soie qu'est ce qu'elles sont
[Musique]
mais les bougies les bouchers les
bougies on s'amuse mais non ça c'est de
la triche sahel et des places mais qu
elle déplace les bougies la [ __ ]
tellement les bougies les bougies les
bougies les bougies les bougies at-il ou
non je rallume je rallume
non il faut lui [ __ ] la zone rouge et
non non tu n'as pas réussi à s'échapper
de la pièce on y retourne aussitôt c'est
parti on lance le petit rituel la mecque
on va faire les choses bien ok alors je
rallume trois sur quatre
comme ça j'aurai juste allumer adana
quand il sera rentré elle est rentrée je
ferme la fenêtre up et j'allume toutes
les bougies
voilà la haye les baisers elle fait
tomber le miroir parce qu elle est
vénère ça se passe bien ça se passe très
bien elle sort des chiottes
je tiens la chasse d'eau puisque je suis
un jeune garçon alors voilà j'ai la
moitié de clés comment j'ai fait pour la
deuxième particularité fallait bloquer
la porte aux plats la porte est bloqué
donc là il va céder leurs parts au choix
qu'elle a pété la chaise 1 tout comme sa
réserve
elle va passer en mode mon fils et de
trois sur 20 juin bloody mary bloody
mary bloody mary est bon at on eu un
bail eu un bug leurs morceaux de cleck à
voler mais il est tombé dans le vide en
fait il y avait un morceau plus qu'à
regarder un bug
il ya deux moitiés de clément non
adacore fait je les assemble super c'est
pas un bug donc ça se fête
qu'est ce que je fais parce que je suis
un jeune homme insolent je la remplace
ok là ça pue c'est là que ça passe en
mode très très très glauque et que
j'aime pas du tout c'est là il va
falloir trouver les bougies faut se
concentrer
il faut que je trouve faut que ces trous
là là bas là il y en a une la
mitoyenneté n'importe quoi mais non mais
qu'est mort mais royal et tu vois il est
bloqué le tiroir il est buggé je peux
pas ouvrir
on n'a pas eu le temps non bon ok cette
petite ldp d'affaires
il faut que j'aie ce que voudrait sur
les bougies ok elle a pété la chaise il
faut que je reste concentré sur les
bouches aya si on a deux a déjà c'est
bien ça le mène lionhead la commune en
bas en haut et en bas
yes c'est bon c'est bon on bouge il
manque une bougie une bougie ont bougé
manque ou à l'ère où elle est là ouais
ouais ouais c'est bon du coup il a donné
jusqu'à paris ou pas - et là du coup
j'ai plus qu'à taper le code pour
schengen et je peux lui tirer dessus et
je vais me faire plaisir à mon pote tu
es au jeu de miroirs jeu voire du mal à
expliquer les dégâts de la salle de bain
pour des parents je vais pas te mentir
si je leur dis que j'étais juste en
train de chier non pas trop y croire
voilà donc là qu'est ce que tu as gagné
dans cette histoire personne va 3 600
mille euros travaux dans la salle de
bains bilan est ce que vous invoquez des
esprits chez vous bien sûr ce qu'ils
font et bien voilà c'est la fin de
saison ne s'est pas l'aimer ça vous a
plu
merci à vous regarder partout bien sûr
tout le monde au pis
[Musique]